[Música]
bienvenidos a nuestra sección de
economía aquí en directo américa hoy
está con nosotros jorge hurtado jorge un
placer volverlo a saludar en el estudio
y vamos a hablar de eeuu porque el
presidente del banco central de ese país
reconoció hoy los riesgos de una posible
recesión es tomaría clara como
consecuencia de una agresiva política
monetaria que está ejecutando la reserva
federal de ese país en busca de
controlar una inflación más alta en 40
años que vive eeuu power brindó
testimonio frente al comité bancario del
senado y dijo que el mundo enfrenta un
entorno global incierto que puede
ocasionar inclusive nuevas sorpresas en
materia de inflación la reserva federal
de ese país buscará un aterrizaje suave
de la economía aunque powell admitió que
es una tarea desafiante una de las
noticias más seguidas por los inversores
es la subida de los tipos de interés y
powell adelantó que nuevos aumentos
serán apropiados en ese país los precios
históricos de la gasolina llevaron a la
inflación al 86 por ciento los últimos
12 meses que terminaron en mayo la
semana pasada la reserva federal elevó
su tipo de interés de referencia en tres
cuartos de puntos porcentuales su mayor
su vida en casi tres décadas hasta un
rango del 15 entre el 1 75% la
desaceleración económica que el aumento
de los tipos de interés ocasiona provoca
temores a una recesión en la economía
más grande del mundo escuchamos la
intervención de powell el día de hoy
resultado usted de acuerdo con la
perspectiva de que si los tipos de
interés suben demasiado podría llevarnos
a una recesión ciertamente es una
posibilidad no es nuestro resultado
previsto en absoluto pero ciertamente es
una posibilidad y francamente los
acontecimientos de los últimos meses en
todo el mundo han hecho más difícil que
logremos lo que queremos que es una
inflación del 2% y un mercado laboral
todavía fuerte el broker jorge y
seguimos en eeuu porque el presidente
joe biden está intentando quitarle el
impuesto a la gasolina bailén pidió al
congreso suspender por tres meses el
impuesto federal sobre la gasolina para
ayudar a combatir los elevados precios
que mencionamos anteriormente by the end
que es el presidente que en la educación
pasa factura en encuestas de popularidad
dijo que desafiará a las principales
compañías petroleras a que aporten ideas
sobre cómo recuperarla pasea de refinado
inactiva durante una reunión con el
secretario de energía que se va a
realizar este jueves pero la suspensión
del impuesto federal sobre la gasolina
de 18,4 centavos por galón y el impuesto
sobre el diesel de 24 centavos requiere
la aprobación del congreso lo que la
convierte de alguna forma en una idea
simbólica porque no está en sus manos la
propuesta restaría al fondo fi de
usuario de carretera son los 10 mil
millones de dólares en ingresos no
percibidos y ahora vamos a rusia el
presidente vladimir putin firmó decretos
para buscar el pago de las obligaciones
rusas y específicamente para intentar
pagar la deuda externa de rusia ya que
el país se encuentra al borde del impago
según el gobierno tiene los fondos para
pagar pero no ha podido hacerlo por
precisamente por estas sanciones de
occidente si acusa a occidente de llevar
a rusia a un impago artificial ahora
putin dio al gobierno 10 días para
elegir a los bancos que se van a
encargar de los pagos de los euros bonos
bajo un nuevo esquema lo que sugiere que
rusia considerará cumplida sus
obligaciones de deudas cuando pague a
los tenedores de bonos rulos según el
decreto el tipo de cambio se basará en
el tipo de mercado interno de divisas
ruso el día del pago los 40 mil millones
de dólares de obligaciones rusas
pendientes de pago se han convertido en
el foco de las sanciones financieras
impuestas por occidente así como las
contramedidas que está imponiendo moscú
a nivel interno y en chile la mayor
productora de cobre del mundo entró en
huelga explíquenos por qué se trata de
los trabajadores de la corporación
nacional del cobre codelco una empresa
estatal chilena dedicada a la
explotación y exportación del cobre que
iniciaron una huelga indefinida por el
cierre de una fundición en una de las
regiones más contaminadas del país la
federación de trabajadores del cobre
apoya la protesta que según cálculos le
costaría a codelco unos 20 millones de
dólares al día los sindicatos que
califican de arbitrario el cierre de
esta fundación llamada ventanas ubicada
a unos 140 kilómetros al oeste de
santiago exigen al gobierno que invierta
unos 54 millones de dólares para adecuar
esta planta a los más altas más altos
estándares de ambientales el cierre se
da luego qué 9 de junio unas 115
personas en su mayoría estudiantes
sufrieran una intoxicación por dióxido
de azufre liberado por la industria
pesada lo que provocó el cierre de los
colegios de la zona la semana pasada el
presidente gabriel boric incrementó y
arremetió más bien dicho contra el
historial de contaminación del medio
ambiente en ese país jorge y cuál es la
cifra del día la cifra del día es 13 mil
800 dólares eso generó al año un
anfitrión promedio nervi embi en eeuu en
2021 esto representa un incremento del
85 por ciento respecto al año anterior
un gran aumento jorge gracias por toda
la información económica y nosotros
seguimos aquí con el debate
[Música]